hello everyone and welcome to a most
wonderful game that was suggested to me
via email by a user named yobara 10 and
it's a really a brilliant brilliant game
from the 1965 ussr championship was
played in tallinn in estonia and it
features uh vladis mckenna's and uh of
course david bronstein who needs no
introduction on this channel i hope uh
but uh a few words about laras mckenna's
uh he played chess pretty much his
entire life originally from estonia uh
himself he won the 1930 estonian
championship then he uh immigrated to
lithuania uh where he won the 1936 uh
lithuanian championship and uh well he
had a very very productive chess career
like i said played chess his entire life
uh in 1937 he even uh drew a game
against alexander alejan uh who was the
world champion maybe it was in that uh
part where uh alejand lost the world
church championship to max yuva uh but
uh you know regardless it was still uh i
mean alexander alejan
uh so
definitely a strong player that that's
what i uh wanted to to tell you and he
continued playing uh for example this is
a game from 1965 and he's been playing
since the 30s and well just an
incredibly strong player that played
chess his entire life which is very
important for this game as uh he is
playing david bronstein who is one of
those players that everyone agrees that
is probably the strongest player who
never became world champion as this set
of many players like uh they say this
about paul cares they said it's about uh
vastly vanchuk uh they say this about
well there just are these players that
are so strong but never really uh got a
crack at the title okay david bronstein
did get a crack at the title and he was
very very close to winning it but he
never quite did at some point i do hope
to make like a very short uh brunchtime
saga as he was not a world champion so
maybe not an extensive one but um yeah
hope i will be able to do one so getting
back to this game it's really really
awesome as it features the old indian
defense that brawnstein is playing and
um well he just shows how uh even though
it's not considered the main weapon it
can still be used
you know uh
to a good cause and it has some perks
that for example the king's indian
defense doesn't have you don't have the
g6 pawn uh well the g pawn on g6 so
white can't really advance his h pawn
and take advantage of you of your
weakness uh but you'll see what happens
in this game uh so let's dive straight
into it so mckenna has the white pieces
and he opens with d4 we have knight to
f6 by braunstein c4 sorry about that
uh and uh d6 uh by braunschweig we have
knights to c3 and now d6 this is the c6
this is the check variation of the old
indian defense we have e4 now mckenna's
grabs the full center and now uh e5 and
of course even though you could trade
here then no one ever does this because
after captures capture cs okay you can
trade queens for example queen capture
78 and you uh
uh you know take away blacks castling
privileges but it doesn't matter if
anyone is better here is black so
instead just the d5 here we grab more
space in the center bishop to e7 and now
bishop to e2 we have castles here and
knight to f3 and here braunstein plays
knight to a6 you could play knight to d7
braunstein puts it on a6 he says later
on it's gonna be put to c5 also it
prevents white from rapidly expanding
with b4
and uh well once white makes his
intentions clear we will probably play
knight to c5 and it will come with stamp
or this knight is already attacking the
e4 pawn so white will not be in time to
chase away our knight with b4
uh and uh well uh white castles here and
the bishop to d7 and here white says all
right uh braunshawn is doing something
very very slow here and it's very odd he
has a knight on a6 so i'm going to play
knight to e1 and i'm going to start
opening up the position with f4 and
interestingly as of move 9 knight to the
e1 uh it was uh uh that this position
never happened again uh so here how do
you uh continue development as black
here well braunschweig plays queen to c8
and this is such a powerful move in the
position that we really need to remember
uh when playing our own games because
usually when you're playing a chess game
you know that
okay there are these general squares
where the knight belongs you know that
the knights belong on maybe f6 and c6
you know that the bishop should be on d7
and e7 unless their fiance are done g7
and b7 you know you want to bring the
rooks into the game maybe c a d a rook
this comes to e8 or or d8 uh but
bronstein has a different idea this
bishop came from f8 to e7 and now
brunstein by moving the queen to c8 he's
preparing this maneuver bishop to e7
d8 and then to b6 and then the dark
square bishop that is not doing all that
much here will be a very strong bishop
here on this diagonal so this is
braunstein's plan
and while uh maybe a modern man's master
would go something like king to h1 right
away amicanus first starts with knight
to d3 now preparing f4 and bishop to d8
braunschweig continues his plan with f4
uh mikanos also says all right you do
your thing i'm gonna do mine uh and now
c captures on d5 first we have a trade
in the center and now knight the c5 this
is the idea that braunstein had
now white is not in time to chase away
the knight as the e4 pawn is hanging so
the knight was only placed on a6
temporarily
and if you trade here for example knight
captures we're going to play queen
captures on c5 and not much
is happening here for uh for white if
king h1 we can even play a queen to d4
and now it's black who's dictating the
tone of the battle so instead after this
knight the c5 you could maybe defend it
with knight to f2 okay add a defender
here but uh instead we just have f
captures on e5 uh so forcing the trade
knight c captures an uh sorry knight
knight f captures on e4 knight captures
an e4 we have knight captures on e4 and
now bishop to e3 uh mechanics uh
mechanism develops the bishop here and
then now comes the bishop to b6 and i
believe this is the move that braunstein
is most proud of in this game even
though you guys will probably think it's
a different one uh but the bishop to b6
is just an incredibly powerful move
because braunstein has a very active
knight on e4 and now how do you defend
the bishop on e3 you can't play queen d2
and the knight covers that there's no
way to move the bishop uh you can't play
queen to c1 because we just trade queen
captures rook captures and then we pick
up a free bishop so the only thing white
can do here is to trade dark square
bishops and this means that brawnstein
now gets the open a file or rather the
semi-open a file for his rook so bishop
captures on b6 a captures on b6 and now
we have rook to f4 trying to get rid of
this knight uh from this very active
square but now brunstein plays knight to
c5 he says this is a small combination
to take control of the dark squares and
now how can white continue here well if
you if you trade here then again just
queen captures on c5 checking you one
and we're going to capture on e5 and
black is just much much better here so
instead after knight to c5 uh mechanism
grabs the pawn on d6 and now comes
braunstein's idea knight captures on d3
queen captures on d3 and now queen to c5
with check and okay you might think uh
well why why why should white have
played king to h1 in the first place
when he can just move the king uh you
know with temple when he is being
checked but uh most of the times that's
not how chess works uh king to h1 we
have queen captures on d6 now attacking
the rook here and here uh rook to h4 now
mckenna moves the rook away from harm's
way and also threatens checkmate on h7
so h6 uh braunstein uh defends this by
also creating some breeding room for his
king and he says this is a very
important aspect of this game as the
black king has a breeding
some breeding room to
you know
lean on to and the white king does not
now that king to h1 has been played and
how do you get this rook into the game
you really can't because the a2 pawn is
hanging so white uh absolutely has to
waste the move to play something like
pawn to a3 this is exactly what mikanos
does now comes rook after e8 putting
pressure on the bishop but also putting
a rook on the open e file and bishop to
f3 this is a great square for the bishop
we put more defense to the d5 pawn and
now comes queen to e5 and this is an
extremely poisonous move by by bernstein
uh you can see that uh some of the
threats are very very visible now you
can see that the white's back rank is
very very weak and you have this queen
to e1 idea we're going to sacrifice the
queen
and if rook captures we're going to
deliver checkmate for the moment this is
not possible because the queen can also
defend with queen to f1 but there are
not all that many great moves white can
play here so what you could do uh for
example if you play something like rook
to b1 then it's a problem then queen to
e1 definitely will result um
in a loss because if you play queen to
f1 now now the problem is the rook on h4
is hanging so the background checkmate
isn't your only problem so rook to b1
can't really be played
the only thing you can play here is
queen to d4
and rook to d4 but for a very specific
reason if you play queen to d4 queen to
e1 then you can retreat with queen to g4
for example queen to d4 and now of
course if queen to e1 with check
we first capture the queen and after
rook captures now we block with queen to
g1 and we survived the attack there's uh
not all that much uh black can claim
here to to be advantageous for him and
another thing we can play rook to d4
that also
will work for us because if now queen to
e1 we can play queen to f1 and now the
there's no rook on h4 hanging so we've
defended well however uh in the game
mechanics played rook to b4 he said uh
as my b2 pawn was hanging let's just
defend the pawn and well let's also just
get the rook away from the h4 square
because that's the problem pretty much
in in all of these combinations the uh
the combination of the back rank mate
with queen to e1 uh in uh addition to
the rook being an h4 this is what will
be white ruin however he misses one very
important thing here and it's uh one
that makes this game uh
well just spectacular and this is
probably the move you guys will enjoy
the most even though i still think
bishop to b6 was braunstein's favorite
move of the game
but feel free to pause the video here
and try to find this absolutely crushing
idea braunstein played here while i give
you a couple of seconds
so for those of you who were able to do
it uh congratulations as you are a true
spotter of x-raying moves and for those
of you who just want to enjoy the show
it is rook captures an a3 this one i
believe deserves to be played out in
slow motion let's do this rook captures
on a3 and uh believe it or not it was in
this position on move 24 that vladis
mckenna's resigned the game as there is
nothing more to be done here even though
the rook can be captured with the pawn
with the white rook and with the white
queen
none of it works
because now of course you can see that
if the pawn captures then the rook on a1
is hanging and that's a big deal as that
rook was supposed to help white defend
the background mate and now even after
rook to b1 blocking check we play rook
to e1 with check and now after rook
captures we're gonna play queen captures
queen to f1 queen captures on f1 will be
checkmate so capturing with the pawn
doesn't really work capturing with the
rook also doesn't really make much sense
because we've removed one of the
defenders from the back rank after queen
f1 this will be checkmate and of course
after rook captures on a3 there's only
one thing left and that is queen
captures but now we just give up the
queen queen to e1 check rook captures
and rook captures on e1
so really really a spectacular game
thank you so much for for suggesting
such a such a brilliancy but like i said
i mean if i if i had to show brunchtime
games for for like an entire year i
would be a very happy person and i'm i'm
pretty sure you guys
wouldn't mind so uh you can see how uh
backrack rank issues are a huge problem
uh like i said branchline had the h6
played his king had an escape square uh
if uh you know uh the the position took
a wrong turn for him but white did not
after king to h1 there was no square for
the white king and this uh uh this
attacking move that white played this
rook to h4 to threaten checkmate uh was
the well basically the the tool that
allowed braunstein to combine not only
the idea of the of the back ranked mate
but also the idea of attacking the b2
pawn but also the idea that rook
captures an a3 was an idea because the
rook on a1 was hanging
and i mean it's just
uh what what to say this is one one
brilliant game so really hope you guys
enjoyed it and that you will uh well
appreciate braunstein a little bit more
because i know you guys really
appreciate him he's such a spectacular
player i i should do more videos on him
definitely
and i did promise you that uh we will
continue uh the the the saga on his uh
well famous famous tournament book the
the surrey tournament of 1953 but we'll
get to that no worries so that's the
game i hope you guys enjoyed it and that
you've learned something you know not
just because it's called the old indian
defense doesn't mean it's bad uh i would
like to thank dave ellis prata mahajan
usf d efr usfdfri and nicolas padal for
your contribution to my channel thank
you a lot to really appreciate it as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank you for watching and i
will see you soon continuing to check up
on your wonderful suggestions such as
this one and whatever else happens in
the chess world so thank you all i will
see you soon and have an excellent rest
of your day